[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live der russische krieg in der ukraine
mitten bei uns in europa verändert
unsere sicherheits ordnung seine
auswirkungen die machen nämlich nämlich
nicht an irgendwelchen landesgrenzen
halt und so gibt es jetzt eine
entwicklung und zwar finnland und
schweden jahrzehntelang militärisch
neutral wollen nun mitglieder der nato
werden sie haben sorge um ihre eigene
sicherheit denn finden zum beispiel hat
eine grenze zu russland von ganzen 1300
kilometern ist diese grenze lang und
morgen wollen die beiden länder ihre
mitgliedsanträge ihre nato-mitglieds
anträge einreichen heute stimmte eine
riesige mehrheit im finnischen parlament
dafür und doch ganz so einfach wird das
wahrscheinlich nicht gehen denn es wurde
schon angekündigt von einem nato
mitglied nämlich der türkei dass sie
gegen diese aufnahme sei und dass sie
dagegen stimmen wollen würde und
deswegen ist das thema heute bei uns das
machtspiel in der nato und eure fragen
und kommentare dazu könnt ihr jederzeit
per mail stellen oder auch im stream und
vor allem jetzt auch zuerst an unsere
korrespondenten nämlich einmal in
brüssel anne gellinek und jörg brase für
uns in der türkei hallo
hallo
zuerst zu dir was hörst du von der nato
gibt es schon reaktionen auf diese
drogen der türkei eben nicht zustimmen
zu wollen also das problem schwelt ja
schon seit ein paar tagen die türkische
opposition hat sich ja immer mal so ein
bisschen verändert mal hat der türkische
präsident mit nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg telefoniert und gesagt ja ja
das würde schon irgendwie laufen dann
kam aber der türkische außenminister und
hat gesagt auf gar keinen fall es gibt
vorbehalte offiziell und die hat erdogan
auch gestern abend in ankara noch mal
bekräftigt vorbehalte gegen schweden und
finnland speziell dass sie
terroristen unterstützen würden das
zielt auf die pkk und andere gruppen die
die in der türkei als terror
organisation eingestuft werden die
tatsächlich vor allem in schweden
zuflucht finden und deshalb ist erdogan
das schiebt er zumindest offiziell vor
als grund deshalb sei er gegen den
beitritt von
von schweden und finnland zur nato jörg
brase unserer korrespondenten der türkei
wir haben gehört also was man hier so
weit weg von außen also von erdogan hört
was hörst du in der türkei noch für
gründe was was sagt erdogan sind seine
beweggründe dem also nicht zustimmen zu
wollen
ja ich glaube es gibt eine ganze reihe
von gründen die das motiviert haben
könnten dass der präsident sich gegen
die aufnahme von finnland und schweden
in die nato stellt als ich das erste mal
gehört habe dass erdogan das ablehnt und
begründet eben mit mit dem argument dass
schweden eine brutstätte des terrorismus
sei da habe ich mir gedacht na ja das
ist jetzt ein politisches zeichen
richtung moskau dass man nicht alles
mitmachen will was der westen plant die
türkei gerät sich als vermittler
zwischen russland und der ukraine man
unterhält gute kontakte nach moskau nach
kiew man brauche russland als
energielieferant und insofern wollte man
da vielleicht ein politisches zeichen
setzen dass man da tatsächlich nicht
alles mitmacht und das zweite was mir
dann ein spiel waren die wahlen im
nächsten jahr die präsidentschaftswahl
und natürlich kann man diese wahl nicht
gewinnen in der türkei wenn man nicht
bestimmt auftritt im kampf gegen den
terrorismus und da dachte ich mir dass
das sicherlich auch eine motivation
gewesen sein könnte dass man da die
nation das nationalistischen wähler
mobilisiert aber man muss auch einfach
sehen dass die türkei in der tat ein
sehr angespanntes verhältnis zur nato
hat und zwar weil man glaubt dass die
eigenen sicherheitsinteressen da nicht
genügend berücksichtigt werden das gilt
zum einen zum beispiel was den umgang
mit griechenland angeht im streit um
erdgas bohrungen im mittelmeer
da fühlt man sich eher von den europäern
und der nato im stich gelassen in der
auseinandersetzung mit griechenland aber
eben auch was zum beispiel den kauf von
luftabwehrsystem angeht die türkei hätte
gerne amerikanische peter jetzt gekauft
die waren zu teuer dann hat man gesagt
okay dann gehen wir jetzt nach russland
und kaufen das sind halt da was ja zu
bekanntermaßen großen spannungen in der
nato führte und als letztes vielleicht
noch kurz angeführt das ist dieser diese
grenzsicherung die türkei argumentiert
immer dass sie die eigenen grenzen
sichern wo es eben gegen die pkk im
nord-irak oder gegen den syrischen
ableger die epg in nordsyrien nach dem
einmarsch in nordsyrien habe neben
schweden und finnland ein waffenembargo
gegen die türkei ausgesprochen und das
nimmt man schweden und finnland übel und
das könnte auch ein grund gewesen sein
dass man einfach da mal ein punkt machen
musste über viele von dir angesprochenen
punkte werden wir in dieser sendung an
noch ausführlich sprechen aber wir
schauen erst mal rein an den durst einen
beitrag für uns gemacht und auch einmal
kompakt die ganze lage und die
problematik zusammengefasst und wir
schauen uns mal zusammen an
nun also auch schweden in stockholm
unterschreibt außenministerin an linde
feierlich und vor kameras den
beitrittsantrag für die nato
es ist ein bedeutsamer ein sehr ernster
moment und es fühlt sich so an als ob
wir das tun von dem wir denken dass es
das beste für schweren ist
damit ist es offiziell schweden und
finnland streben nach jahrzehnten der
neutralität in die nato um schutz vor
russland zu suchen das militärbündnis
empfängt sie mit offenen armen denn von
beiden ländern würde die allianz
erheblich profitieren
finnland hat der direkten grenze zu
russland wegen nie bei der armee gespart
und verfügt im kriegsfall über
185.000 soldaten plus 238 tausend
reservisten
schweden besitzt eine kleinere armee
bringt aber moderne u boote und gut
ausgestattete kampfflugzeuge mit ein
doch es gibt noch ein problem
30 nato mitgliedsländer müssen zustimmen
eins davon die türkei ist dagegen
präsident erdogan wirft schweden und
finnland vor kurdische separatisten zu
unterstützen die die türkei als
terroristen betrachtet
wie können wir ihn trauern schweden ist
eine brutstätte für terrororganisationen
die nato versucht den konflikt
herunterzuspielen und dabei
herauszufinden was erdogan wirklich will
der deutsche kanzler optimistisch
so zuversichtlich wie der nato
generalsekretär dass das auch schnell
und zügig gelingen wird mit der
unterstützung aller länder auch der
türkei als nato-mitglied es wäre ein
express beitritt schon im herbst könnten
finnland und schweden nato-mitglieder
sein wenn die türkei einlegt
die nato versucht herauszufinden was
erdogan wirklich will sagst du an wir
haben kommentare rein bekommen bei uns
hier im stream bei facebook zum beispiel
schreibt
erdogan erpresst die eu und die nato mit
vorgeschobenen gründen für das veto
damit isoliert er sich doch nun weiter
jörg glaubst du denn dass erdogan aber
eigentlich grundsätzlich gesprächsbereit
ist und dass das vielleicht alles jetzt
noch gar nicht so in stein gemeißelt ist
was er da so sagt
ich denke schon ich glaube nicht dass
die türkei tatsächlich das veto einlegt
und den bruch mit der mit der nato
provoziert aber wie ich ihm erklärt habe
es gibt viele gründe politische gründe
innenpolitische gründe aber auch
aussenpolitische gründe für präsident
erdogan da jetzt mal ein veto einzulegen
zumindest im vorfeld natürlich kann man
sich auch vorstellen dass der forderung
stellt an die nato an die europäer denn
die wunschliste der türkei ist in der
tat lang und ich denke dass es jetzt ein
politisches zeichen war das ja aus
aussenden wollte ich kann mir aber nicht
vorstellen dass die türkei tatsächlich
ein beitritt von finnland und schweden
verhindern würde anne wenn es klappen
sollte also ein beitritt von finnland
und schweden im herbst in die nato wie
würde das denn die nato verändern es
würde die nato verändern einmal in der
hinsicht dass der gesamte ostseeraum
plötzlich ganz von der nato sozusagen
umschlossen ist denn bisher waren ja die
baltischen staaten da als vorposten
gelegen und es würde die sicherheit der
baltischen staaten erheblich erhöhen
wenn schweden und finnland und eben
diese große grenze zu russland da auch
noch nato gebiet wäre militärisch
gesehen ist es das habe ich ja auch in
dem beitrag so ein bisschen versucht zu
erklären er ein gewinn für die nato die
nato spricht von sicherheits zuwachs für
das bündnis weil eben die finden eine
sehr große stärke armee habe
entschuldigung und weil man sich davon
verspricht das eben das bündnis ja eben
mehr mehr eine größere schlagkraft hat
wenn wenn diese beiden länder beitreten
würden vielen dank für die einschätzung
anne gellinek in brüssel und jörg brase
in die abag ihr in der türkei
und wir schauen jetzt nochmal genauer
auf das was erdogan nach außen sagt und
was er aber vielleicht wirklich meint
sein zwiespalt zwischen ukrainischer und
russischer seite ein beitrag von moritz
neuss
die nato präsentiert sich seit ausbruch
des ukraine kriegs so geschlossen wie
nie wäre da nicht der türkische
präsident erbt war spätestens seitdem er
2009/10 luftabwehrsysteme von russland
gekauft hat ist das verhältnis mit der
türkei angespannt denn die usa ließen
als reaktion einen deal mit der türkei
über die lieferung von f 35 kampfjets
platzen und verhängten sanktionen gegen
ankara ein möglicher grund für die
türkische boykott haltung gegenüber der
nato nord erweiterung erklärt der
luxemburgische außenminister asselborn
im zdf monat also wissen dass viele
basis funktionieren in der türkei und
manchmal nicht die mentalität vor allem
von erdogan ja auch sehr davon geprägt
es geht glaube ich riskiere es zusagen
nicht um die kurdenfrage
erdogan hatte schon zuvor in
verschiedenen militär konflikten gegen
nato interessen argumentiert und wie in
syrien oder libyen eine enge abstimmung
mit russland gepflegt wir wissen dass
die türkei in den letzten jahren viel
mit russland kooperiert hat dass wir
schon vor dem krieg als haupt wird was
sagen hauptrivale oder potenzieller
gegner der nato sich entwickelt hat von
daher hat die türkei in der nato ohnehin
schlecht
zwar war es die türkei die ukraine und
russland einen tisch gebracht hat doch
erdogan steht zwischen den fronten
einerseits ist er von russischen
erdgaslieferungen
abhängig andererseits ist die ukraine
ein wichtiger käufer türkischer
kampfdrohnen mit denen sie heute
russische truppen bekämpft auch nichts
davon will erdogan verzichten
wir können es uns weder mit der ukraine
noch mit russland verderben
es ist eine gratwanderung zwischen
russland und dem westen so nato könnten
schon im herbst auch schweden und
finnland gehören wäre da nicht der
türkische präsident erdogan
wir können dazu jetzt all unsere fragen
stellen an christian rackl er ist leiter
der heinrich böll stiftung in istanbul
schirm guten abend herr
buckle sie beobachten erdogan und seine
politik seit jahren sie leben selbst in
istanbul in der türkei auch an sie
erstmal die frage was will erdogan
wirklich
also ja dass er gerade in den beitragen
sagt wirklich wissen können wir ist
natürlich nicht ich glaube aber es gibt
eine ganze reihe von kunden angesprochen
worden der kommende wahlkampf
grundsätzlich die die unzufriedenheit
mit der nato in den letzten jahren in
ordnung dass man allein gelassen worden
ist aber ich glaube das sollte man auch
nicht komplett ausschließen das ist den
präsidenten unter umständen wirklich um
um diese thematik angesprochen hat geht
das ist etwas das immer wieder
vorgebracht wird was auch sehr viel
unterstützung hier im land sind und zwar
auch sowohl von anhängern anhängerinnen
des präsidenten als auch von leuten aus
der opposition dass man den eindruck hat
die sicherheitsinteressen der türkei die
werden nicht ernst genommen und das
nicht nur von ländern die vielleicht ein
schwieriges verhältnis oder ein nicht
ganz so das verhältnis gehabt haben in
den letzten jahren sondern eben auch von
denen die eigentlich die engsten
verbündeten sein sollen ein paar unserer
user haben kritische vermutungen detlef
perschl zb schrieb uns per mail wenn
erdogan wieder geld kassieren das ist
seine vermutung die würden sie das
einschätzen
ich glaube nicht dass es in jedem fall
jetzt um geld geht auf jeden fall nicht
im sinne von
also pflicht direktüberweisung wie das
wetter oder habe ich mal
direktüberweisung gelder wie es gibt zum
beispiel eine flüchtlings je gegeben hat
aber es kann natürlich schon sein dass
es um finanzielle interessen geht also
wenn es zum beispiel diskussion geben
sollte um dieses kampfjet programm was
gescheitert ist mit den amerikanern f-35
da sagen wir haben da etliche milliarden
investiert und eingezahlt wir kriegen
diese flugzeuge nicht aber das geld das
kriegen wir auch nicht zurück also wenn
dann würde ich sagen er indirekt geht zu
geld dann haben sie ein beitrag ja auch
schon gehört erdogan scheint in der
zwickmühle zu sein was scheint ihm oder
was wird ihm am ende vielleicht
wichtiger seien eigene interessen oder
eben sein verhältnis zur nato
das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen wir
haben am samstag gesehen dass ein
wichtiger enger berater des präsidenten
ibrahim calli schon versucht hat das
ganze ein bisschen zurückzurudern und
gesagt hat es geht jetzt hier erst mal
nicht um ein veto aber es geht natürlich
schon darum dass das schweden und
finnland sich mal überlegen müssen was
für eine politik die das fahren ich
glaube das zeigt dass es schon personen
im umkreis des präsidenten gibt die
erkennen das sollte man sich wirklich
gegen einen nato-beitritt stellen dass
das sehr starke konsequenzen für das
ansehen der türkei für die stellung der
türkei im bündnis hätte aber ich glaube
es ist auch ganz gut sich an voran die
damit zu zeigen wir hatten erst im
letzten winter diese sogenannte
botschafterinnen krise wo der präsident
auf mit so einem handstreich im prinzip
gedroht hat
wichtigste botschafter botschafterin von
wirklich eng verbündeten wie deutschland
wie in den usa aus dem land zu werfen
und das konnte auch nur unter ja
wirklich einem formelkompromiss unter
extremer zuhilfenahme wirklich von
beraterinnen beratern abgewandelt werden
obwohl die konsequenzen natürlich für
die türkei verheerend gewesen wäre ich
glaube das zeigt auch dass man durchaus
ernst nehmen muss dass wir in einem land
leben in der türkei in dem eben wirklich
eine person der präsident so unglaublich
viel zu sagen dass die außenpolitik
angeht und auch vielleicht nicht ganz
statt von manchmal rationalen erwägungen
aber eben auch zum beispiel wird den
dingen die es in deutschland gibt dem
parlament oder ähnliches gehen wir noch
mal dann detailliert auf die vorwürfe
für die im raum stehen aber auch
erdogans beweggründe und gaben gehen wir
dann noch mal drauf ein zum einen jetzt
erstmal erdogan wirft schweden vor
brutstätte für terrororganisationen
zitat zu sein wen oder was meint ihr
hier genau was ist da dran
es gibt um zwei organisationen das eine
ist die pkk beziehungsweise mit ihr
verbündete
strukturen wir wissen die pkk ist nicht
nur eine militärische organisation daran
hat ein sehr großes ziviles vorfeld das
in verschiedenen europäischen ländern
unter anderem auch in deutschland
rekrutiert gelder akquiriert zum teil
durch kriminelle machenschaften aber
eben auch politisch in erscheinung tritt
durch lobby organisationen durch
demonstration schweden ist da sicherlich
nicht das wichtigste land diese länder
sind deutschland und frankreich und
belgien aber es gibt dort gewisse
strukturen das zweite ist die sogenannte
grünen organisation die vermutlich
anteil an gescheiterten putschversuch
von 2016 hat jedenfalls macht der
präsident sie dafür verantwortlich
die betreibt aus schweden heraus auch
zumindest social media kanäle ungewisse
lobbyorganisation für ihre zwecke das
problem ist vieles was der präsident da
sagt und die vorwürfe bezüglich
terrorismus die
entsprechenden was zum beispiel wenn es
mal auslieferungsverfahren und ähnliches
geht oft nicht den standards die
europäische gerichte daran legen würden
die terror definition in der türkei ist
sehr sehr
wacklig sehr sehr weit gefasst und
das ist etwas auf deren basis auf
europäische amerikanische gerichte zum
beispiel keine auslieferung vornehmen
können wie die türkei liegt dass ich es
gibt auch einen vorwurf von einer
anderen seite und zwar von dem
luxemburgischen minister asselborn der
wirft erdogan vor er nennt es basar
mentalität was er meint es er sagt es
gehe ihm erdogan also nicht um die
kurdenfrage in schweden in finnland was
es da dran an diesem gegenvorwurf
also ich glaube es ist ein ganzes kommt
aber war von dingen die türkei hat in
den letzten jahren gesagt wir sind über
jahrzehnte ein guter verbündeter in der
nato gewesen wir haben uns engagiert
weil ich das militär mission sieht zum
beispiel in afghanistan auch wenn das
schwierig war als muslimisches land aber
dann als es darauf ankam solidarität von
den bündnispartnern zu erhalten vor
allem ganz und in syrien krieg ging wir
hätten uns
2015/2016 gab es diese großen debatten
darüber ob zum beispiel deutscher
patriot staffeln weiter stationiert
bleiben also sie sagt dann hat die
allianz auf unsere sicherheitsinteressen
keine rücksicht genommen und da geht es
besonders darum dass die amerikaner bis
oder besonders die amerikaner im kampf
gegen islamische staat leben die regatta
die cpg bewaffnet haben und auch
weiterhin unterstützen das war ein
großes logo und man hat den anderen ist
da einfach übergangen worden das was
meine straße bauen sagt kann man
vielleicht sich komplett von der hand
weisen also die türkei hat in den
letzten jahren immer wieder klar gemacht
dass sie sich gerade auch mit
verbündeten mit den europäern auch mit
der bundeswehr wir erinnern uns zum
beispiel diese geißel diplomatie mit
denis hughes
ist eben ein
transaktionale verhältnis das bedeutet
ich gebe euch etwas und dafür bekomme
ich etwas zurück und das ist schon so
dass kein neuer politikansatz ist es
kann also auch verstecken das bedeutet
aber noch nicht dass der andere teil
also dieses ideologische beziehungsweise
die sicherheitsbedenken mit der pkk gar
keine rolle spielen
ich würde gerne nochmal ein paar
kommentare auch erzieher von den
userinnen und usern einbringen wollen
zum einen haben wir hier einen kommentar
von captain nehme ich mal an niveau bei
youtube der schreibt solche machtspiele
wie von der türkei zeigen doch dass die
nato dringend eine reform benötigt das
hier nicht ein einzelnes mitglied alles
torpedieren kann also er nennt es ein
machtspiel dem event bei facebook
schreibt dass erdogan nicht gerade der
verfechter der rechte von menschen ist
sollte jedem klar sein er wird nur als
pufferzone gebraucht das weiß jeder dass
er so entschuldigung also da gibt es
einige die da doch eine ein machtpoker
auf türkischer seite sehen wie würden
sie das dann einschätzen was will er
dann mit einem nein jetzt zwecken wenn
er sagt nein ich stimme da nicht so ich
möchte das nicht
also
das kann ganz verschiedene möglichkeiten
geben und sie können nicht in den kopf
des präsidenten gucken
ich glaube einmal ja es gibt sehr viele
dinge wo man sich ein entgegenkommen der
nato vor allem der amerikaner erwartet
also den erdogan beklagt zum beispiel
auch immer wieder dass er keinen
direkten kontakt zu präsident biden hat
im gegensatz zu denen den jetzt
präsident trump hatte mit dem er viel
und oft sich darauf bemerkt bzw formiert
hat er beklagt immer wieder dass es eben
weiter hinten so unterstützung der ig
bce in syrien gibt
und dass ich glaube das darf man auch
nicht vergessen es gibt einen ganz
starken psychologischen aspekt da drin
dieser eindruck vom westen von
westlichen kräften von europa von
amerika einfach nicht ernst genommen zu
werden und dass die interessen der
türkei darin immer nur zweitrangig sind
es gibt eine interessante
begegnung zwischen der schwedischen
außenministerin am ende und dem
türkischen außenminister davutoglu von
war vor zwei jahren
wo sie in der pressekonferenz in ankara
sagt er wir wünschen uns mehr
meinungsfreiheit pressefreiheit hier
wirklich hier unter starken druck ist
und er kommt im prinzip zurück und sagt
na ja also es gibt hier meinungsfreiheit
aber der westen kommt uns immer mit
diesem doppelstandards sie sprechen zum
beispiel gerne über den ices terrorismus
aber sie tun nichts gegen andere
terroristische gruppen wie die pkk in
ihrem land und ich glaube da ist es
schon wichtig zu verstehen natürlich hat
die türkei nicht die gleichen oder die
türkische führung nicht die gleiche
vorstellung von rechtsstaatlichkeit
davon zum beispiel
werden jetzt genau zur ist und wer nicht
das tun ist aber was ist schon gibt es
gibt einen sehr sehr großen konsens bis
auch wirklich vereinzelte kleinere
gruppierungen
dass die pkk eine reale
sicherheitsbedrohung für den türkischen
staat ist und dass das was in syrien
demonstrieren den letzten jahren
passiert ist dass das natürlich die
sicherheitssituation für die türkei
verschlechtern und die dass der westen
das die amerikaner darüber so
hinweggehen die ganze zeit das löst
schon sehr viel antipathie aus sodass
eben wie gesagt nicht nur und der ahorn
unterstützerinnen und unterstützer
und jetzt gibt es hier natürlich auch
fragen unter anderem von pbg wie man
meine ich bei youtube der sich fragt
also wenn er das wirklich tun sollte
also da ein veto einlegt hat er keine
bedenken vor sagen dass er sanktioniert
würde oder hatte keine bedenken dann vor
den konsequenzen
die frage ist was die konsequenzen sind
also ich kann ihnen sagen ich war vor
sechs mal als in ankara war vor einem
monat glaube ich und habe da gespräche
gehabt auch mit jemand eher hochrangigen
und es ging eben auch um die frage ob es
nicht irgendwann sanktionen geben würde
nicht aufgrund von nato beschlossen
sondern anderen menschenrechtsfragen und
so und mir wurde ganz klar noch mal
dieser blick aus angaben mitgeteilt die
türkei ist auf ihre grund ihrer
geografischen lage so wichtig für den
westen sie ist die südostflanke der nato
wie wir wissen sehr sehr volatil ist da
die jetzt natürlich auch im ukraine
krieg noch mal so viel wichtiger
geworden ist und die die meinung aus
ankara ist ganz klar ihr könnt euch das
nicht leisten mit sanktionen und wir
können darüber streiten ob das richtig
ist oder nicht aber zumindest ist das
tatsächlich der blick gewesen die
perspektive gewesen die in westlichen
hauptstädten in berlin in brüssel in
washington in den letzten jahren
eingenommen worden ist und immer
dominiert hat dazu das muss man auch
sagen gibt es im nato-rat natürlich
eigentlich keine sanktionsmöglichkeiten
also sie können zb das ist ja schon
öfters gefordert worden aus der nach
umzuschmeißen dafür gibt es im prinzip
keinen mechanismus
und angesichts der aktuellen lage in der
ukraine ist es auch sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass es passieren wird
denn wo vor
washington/berlin angst hat ist aktuell
ja in erster linie das wenn man die
türkei zu weit an den rand wenn man sie
alleine lässt dass moskau das russland
sofort da sein wird um diese lehrstelle
zu erfüllen genau wie es den letzten
jahren da gewesen ist um sich als in
anführungszeichen bester verbündeter als
der westen anzugehen die ist ein aktuell
das verhältnis russland türkei erdogan
putin
also es hat mit sicherheit durch diesen
krieg schaden genommen
dass man muss auch immer sehen dass
dieses verhältnis nicht auf augenhöhe
funktionieren natürlich hat der
russische staat sehr viel mehr
druckmittel in nordsyrien im kaukasus
und in schwarz mehr gegen die türkei als
andersherum aber den russen ist es in
den letzten jahren sehr wichtig gewesen
die türkei an ihre seite zu holen wohl
wissen dass sie eben ein dorn im fleisch
der nato sein kann aber eben auch wissen
dass zum beispiel fortschritte in syrien
gegen die türken sehr schwierig werden
das bedeutet muss dann hat weiter ein
interesse daran ihre seite zu erhalten
und man zieht das ja
er hat extra diese diese kampf strom
exportiert in die ukraine und wir wissen
aktuell nicht ob diese lieferung auch
weiter noch weiter gehen die die türkei
hat zumindest eher ein symbolischer art
der dosis zumindest gemacht den bosporus
für die durchfahrt der meisten
russischen kriegsschiffe gesperrt sie
hat den russen auf jetzt untersagt
weiter militärflüge nach syrien zu
unternehmen das bedeutet das sind alles
dinge wo die türkische seite sich
zumindest minimalen handlungsspielraum
erkämpft hat ohne dass dies konsequenzen
gehabt hätte dass man aus bruchsal
abgestraft worden wäre wir sehen zwar
militärischen bewegungen in syrien die
manche 12 stade wissen für eine kleinere
strafaktion halten aber wie gesagt ich
glaube das interesse der russen dieser
allianz am leben zu erhalten ist
mindestens wahrscheinlich ebenso groß
wahrscheinlich sogar größer als das der
tür und gäbe es irgendetwas oder
irgendjemand vielleicht auch der erdogan
umstimmen könnte in dieser sache wie
hart ist bleibt dabei seinem wort wie
würden sie das einschätzen das ist sehr
sehr schwierig zu sagen ich glaube wie
gesagt sie haben von gesehen einige
andere warum sind ein bisschen zurück
gerudert in den letzten tagen der
präsident dem kann man auch viel
vorwerfen seine ideologie und ähnliches
und dann menschenrechtsbilanz mit
sicherheit aber er ist nicht so
ist prinzipiell wird er sehen oder kann
er sollte er es eh dass dieser zug wenn
er bis zum ende durchgehalten wird die
türkei sehr stark beschädigen hätte
gleichzeitig ich verweise noch mal auf
diese botschaft die letztes jahr gehabt
haben wo ist wie gesagt ähnlich gewesen
wäre und die erfahrung die der türkische
präsident in den letzten jahren gemacht
hat ist natürlich auch dass er sich sehr
viel mehr traut als man das in
westlichen auf gentoo und dass er sehr
viel stärker bereit ist auch so eine
harte linie durchzuhalten
deswegen kann man glaube ich noch nicht
sagen wie das genau aussehen wird
und er hat auch jetzt ist heute war
davon die rede dass das schwedische und
finnische delegation sich gerne auf dem
weg nach ankara machen wollen und seine
reaktion ist heute noch einmal gewesen
dass er nichts weißt was das was das
soll denn er würde sich nicht umstimmen
lassen und wie gesagt ist da aber das
müssen wir auch schon noch mal sehen sie
spielt auch ein er spielt einen teil mit
der verletzte stolz die
sicherheitsinteressen der türkei die
real existieren aber
natürlich spielt auch ein ganz schönes
stück ideologie mit und wie wir mit dem
umgehen in westlichen außenpolitik oder
dass wir nicht wissen wie wir damit
umgehen das haben wir glaube ich auch
noch mal ganz deutlich mok rheine krieg
vor augen geführt werden das klingt auf
jeden fall nach einem thema was uns noch
eine weile beschäftigen wird und was
wahrscheinlich noch einige umdrehungen
nimmt danke aber für heute abend schon
einmal für die einschätzung am christian
rackl leiter der heinrich böll stiftung
in istanbul vielen dank
und natürlich auch an euch danke für
eure fragen und eure diskussionen auch
im chat und stream ich habe da immer ein
auge drauf ich hoffe wir konnten hier
einige davon beantworten und wir sind
jederzeit natürlich auch wieder für euch
live in den nächsten tagen bis dahin
tschüss